hello and welcome to met simplified
where we simplify complex medical and
biology topics and make them interesting
on my simplified we share topics mostly
for med and biology students now we have
decided to include more topics on health
awareness interesting medical facts and
much more that most of our new audience
can relate to so if you are new to this
channel consider subscribing in this
video we are going to talk about the
amazing beneficial effects of napping on
high blood pressure
high blood pressure is a dangerous
condition that affects billions of
people around the world also known as
hypertension high blood pressure is a
very common problem that increases the
risk of heart diseases stroke and kidney
failure
in USA alone about 75 million adults
have high blood pressure that's about
one in every three adults high blood
pressure was a predominant cause of
death for more than four lakh Americans
in 2014 alone that's more than 1,100
deaths each day and that figure has been
rising and rising
for every ten people who are diagnosed
with hypertension a further seven remain
undiagnosed and untreated this is
because high blood pressure really
causes symptoms in the early stages and
remains as a silent disease for a very
long time
what does the blood pressure numbers
mean blood pressure is measured using
two numbers the first number called
systolic blood pressure represents the
pressure in your blood vessels when your
heart beats the second number called the
diastolic blood pressure represents the
pressure in your blood vessels when your
heart rests between the beats blood
pressure is measured in millimeters of
mercury blood pressure less than 120 80
millimeters of mercury is considered
normal a blood pressure of more than 140
90 millimeter mercury is considered too
high or hypertension
blood pressure levels higher than normal
for a long time is a dangerous condition
but the good news is that lifestyle
changes can significantly reduce your
numbers and lower your risk without
requiring medications now most of you
know that good habits like more exercise
good diet and less salt are the
cornerstone habits to reduce blood
pressure however the latest research
shows a lifestyle change that decreases
blood pressure significantly midday naps
a new study shows that taking a short 20
to 40 minute nap during the day
helps in significantly reducing blood
pressure in hypertensive patients midday
sleep appeals to lower blood pressure
levels at the same magnitude as the
other lifestyle changes said dr.
mannerless Callie Stratis a cardiologist
in Greece taking a low blood pressure
drug for example can lower your blood
pressure level an average of five to
seven millimeters of mercury while a
40-minute nap if taken regularly can
reduce overall blood pressure levels an
average of five millimeter mercury the
author study said
in this research 212 people participated
with an average age of 62 and systolic
blood pressure of 130 25% of these
people also had diabetes or smoking as a
risk factor then the researchers divided
the participants into two groups and
asked half of the participants to take
midday naps of about 30 to 50 minutes
per day this went on for a couple of
months and after that the study groups
were called in again for further
examination the observations of the
study showed that those who nabbed had
an average systolic blood pressure lower
than 5 millimeters mercury then those
who didn't nap the findings in the study
are significant and promised to
introduce a new lifestyle modification
which can impact the lives of numerous
people in a better way
we obviously don't want to encourage
people to sleep for hours on the end
during the day but on the other hand
they shouldn't feel guilty if they can
take a short nap given the potential
health benefits Calais Tatas said in an
American College of Cardiology news
release in addition to midday naps your
blood pressure readings are what you eat
reducing your salt intake eating more
fruit and vegetables and keeping alcohol
to a limit will lower your blood
pressure also regular exercise
meditation and regular medical check-ups
are also the things that are essential
to have a normal blood pressure but you
know that already don't you talking
about knowing things did you know that
we have launched our new math simplified
merchandise store get your favorite
medical quotes and cool designs on
t-shirts mugs hoodies stickers and just
about anything you can imagine link in
the description below thank you so much
for watching